what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and for
the last few weeks with Omega Beyond
Omega level we've just kind of been
goofing off right just kind of like
having fun and just sort of messing
around and and that kind of a thing we
did Batman with prep time we did pickle
wreck you know we just kind of goofed
off but for real for true the purpose of
the Omega beyond Omega level series is
to take the most powerful characters in
existence whether the planetary threats
or their Universal threats and explain
what it is that makes them so powerful
now within the realm of the Omega level
beyond Omega level this was originally a
Marvel concept Marvel were the ones that
came along and said Omega level and
beyond Omega level and it was confined
to mutants eventually it spread to you
know non mutants and it basically just
said here are some of the most powerful
beams could have incredible powers that
are not mutants like the molecule man or
the Incredible Hulk or something like
that and so we just kind of extended
that off to the realm of like BC and
just kind of use it as an umbrella
concept to explain why beings are so
powerful in comics and what their
abilities are so in this video we are
going to be focusing on the character of
stolen now because storm is so popular I
assume that most people watching this
have at least a passing knowledge of who
she is if you're familiar with the x-men
or Marvel comics at all but just in case
someone with no prior knowledge of comic
books has decided to click on this video
we're going to do as we always do in
this series and briefly run over storm's
origin in history before we dive into
our discussion on her powers so storm
was created by the late and great Len
Wein as well as Dave Cockrum and made
her debut in giant-size x-men issue
number one in 1975 where she was among a
new group of mutants introduced to the
x-men lineup and hopes of improving
sales on the struggling x-men title a
little bit of a fun fact a little bit of
a history here for a lot of people who
don't know the x-men are mainstays right
like people are like I know who the
x-men are the x-men are really popular
there was a time where they weren't and
there was actually a time where Marvel
cancelled their publication and just
issued reprints that was because of the
fact that people didn't really like to
Stanley Jack Kirby Roy Thomas era of the
x-men
it wasn't until Chris Claremont wrote
him in the mid-1970s running up to 1991
that people loved the x-men because we
got the Phoenix saga and the Dark
Phoenix saga and characters like
Wolverine and so on and so forth but
what giant-size x-men number one set out
to do was introduce a more modern
diverse set of mutants from different
parts of the world in hopes of
increasing sales and this is where a lot
of the most recognizable X been joined
the team
Nightcrawler Colossus and of course
storm now as for storms origin she is
the daughter of a Kenyan princess and a
sorceress named nadare who fell in love
with an American photographer named
David Monroe
now they got married moved to Harlem New
York and had a daughter named Aurora
before moving back to Egypt one over all
was extremely young when storm was six
years old her parents were killed in an
aircraft attack during the Suez Crisis
which was actually a real life invasion
of Egypt by Israel in 1956 but living on
the streets of Cairo as an orphan storm
became a skilled pickpocket and she
remained there until the age of 12 when
she set out to the Serengeti to live in
isolation and it was there that storm
first manifested her mutant powers where
she was found by Charles Xavier who
recruited her to join the x-men where
she would adopt the moniker of storm now
another little bit of fun history here
this was not the first time storm
encountered Charles Xavier in fact he
had actually been pickpocketed by storm
and one of the early stories involving
his character in truth it was actually
the origin of the x-men in terms of why
Charles Xavier made him
I cannot remember them off the top of my
head I can't before what issue it was
but it involved the shadow king this
just being who is pure psychic energy
and crazy powerful but Charles Xavier
ended up encountering like this evil
psychic persona which was actually a guy
named a mood for Amahl Farouk who was
basically the Shadow King in disguise
and they engaged in this sort of psychic
battle Charles Xavier ended up winning
and then because of that realized that
with there being characters out there
like the shadow king there had to be
someone who could basically stand in the
way of bad guys and defeat bad mutants
and that's where the x-men came from so
it's actually kind of a cool a little
bit of a little bit of history there
as far as storms mutant powers go is
simply put she can control the weather
with her mind
typically this manifests itself when we
see storm create lightning or strong
winds but her powers actually extend to
all facets of weather storm is able to
manipulate the temperature control
moisture at a molecular level meaning
she can manipulate precipitation as
previously stated storm can produce
lightning caused changes in atmospheric
pressure and create a variety of
meteorological storms including
tornadoes hurricanes snowstorms and
thunderstorms and she can harness her
command of the wind to allow herself to
fly but storms powers do not simply just
end with controlling the weather and she
can also use her powers pretty
effectively against her opponents in
addition to using lightning to attack
enemies she can use her temperature
control to freeze them and her ability
to change barometric pressure to
increase the pressure within her
opponents in her ear causing them severe
physical pain furthermore her wind
abilities allow her to remove all the
air in her opponents lungs
now storms ability to control elemental
forces to such a high degree comes from
her ability to perceive all the
planetary forces at work in our
atmosphere including the electromagnetic
field the ozone layer moisture
temperature of air and electricity storm
is able to create and control basically
every meteorological phenomena that can
be conceived on a scale as small as her
immediate surroundings or as wide
reaching as the entire planet and she
can even manipulate ocean currents
furthermore storms abilities are not
limited to the atmosphere of Earth but
allow her to control the weather on any
planet and she could even control solar
winds and cosmic storms now in terms of
the upper limits of her powers while we
almost certainly have never seen storm
do everything that she's capable of
we have nevertheless seen her perform
some pretty ridiculous feats for example
storm once produced a storm was so
powerful that Psylocke one of the most
powerful telepaths in existence likens
it to the store that sculpted the face
of the planet
when it was young during the same storm
Ororo states that everyone in her
vicinity could be flash frozen in a
matter of seconds and psylocke compares
the temperature to that of deep space on
a separate occasion
storm remarked that actually creates
winds strong enough to hold back a
tsunami that she's actually holding back
on
million tons of water which gives us at
least some idea of how powerful she is
now on the whole when referencing
omega-level mutant in Marvel Comics we
usually don't have to speculate as to
whether or not their own mega level
because nine times out of ten it's
referenced in the comics but with storm
it's not so clear-cut in black panther
issue number 21 a sentinel refers to
storm who's married a black panther at
helping rural Wakanda at the time as a
possible omega-level mutant and then in
issue number nine of Jonathan Hickman's
New Avengers run leading up to the
collapse of the multiverse in secret
Wars at 2015 we see some more possible
evidence of storms Omega level status
when supergiant one of the members of
Thanos is black order remarked that the
only real concern is the black order is
attacking the gene ray school of higher
learning are the omega-level mutant
which is followed by a panel showing
storm Iceman and Rachel gray some have
taken this moment from supergiant as
well as Black Panther number 21 to
basically confirm that storm is Omega
level but supergiant never calls out
storm by name so while it's possible he
was including her in this statement we
can't tell for sure based on some vague
declaration now the other half of this
is that usually whenever they say Omega
level mutants are real threat and then
we see a panel of mutants that basically
means those mutants are confirmed to be
Omega level the problem is it creates
kind of a weird scenario because if we
say a character is Omega level which is
to say capable of destroying all life on
Earth usually they have to be stated as
they are Omega level it's someone
talking about someone else you know oh
man you guys remember x-men Nate gray
yet he's Omega level I mean that's
usually what ends up happening in the
comics there's someone explicitly states
that person that's why you ended up
getting debates and they kind of a
community different things like that now
as far as I'm aware there is no
confirmation or someone saying storm is
an omega-level mutant at least that I
haven't been able to find so if it does
exist out there feel free to link it
down but nonetheless you know using some
measure of common sense reasoning again
we can basically just sort of say that
there's a pretty compelling argument
that storm should be considered Omega
level I mean as we said before and
omega-level mutant is one that has the
ability to become a planetary threat
with beyond Omega level being someone
that is a universal or multiversal
threat and so using that criteria I
think it's fairly obvious that storm is
deserving of the Omega
classification I mean if you think about
the fact that you can control the very
forces of nature and create storms large
enough to cover entire continents then
we can basically deduce pretty easily
that she's able to destroy all life on
Earth either directly or by drastically
altering the entire Earth's climate and
ecosystems making life completely
unsustainable but nonetheless let me
know what you guys think down in the in
the comments section because again you
know we'll say she's potentially Omega
level I would say storm is an
omega-level mutant I would throw it out
there not officially confirmed but I
would say it's pretty much confirmed
we're just kind of waiting on someone to
verify that it's true in the realm of
Marvel Comics but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
also do not forget if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb cork if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment let me know what character you
guys want me to cover next if there's so
many in particular you want me to take a
look at I guess we could do Superman but
I kind of feel I mean Superman
I don't really I don't know why it would
really serve a purpose you know Omega
beyond Omega level Superman ah but
there's a lot of other characters who
are out there that we could definitely
cover in this series Galactus be
incredible hulk different things like
that so let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]